hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to eat hello Gary
Oh my coat thanks Eve yes thank you Gary
for looking after me like Rose bada-boom
God I need the hill real bad okay let's
go Gary
time to move I'm ready let's do this
I'm ready oh good
these lovely paintings is this of gusto
eben whatever his name was I don't even
remember who the guy will
oh there's a peephole yeah let's look in
that's a good idea I don't see anything
probably cuz there was someone looking
back it's an old old old scary story
like something about oh crap oh come on
it's hardly fair press it oh come on
that's hardly fair blue button yeah why
not you know what Oh what
oh I get it I need to press them all
sequentially like spirits dwell so as to
oh you could have said something about
the exit wait oh oh no oh oh wait no no
no no no I can solve it I could solve
the puzzle
I could've solved it I really could have
solved it I know I could have milk
puzzle uh I have not Oh
pieces are white like milk no picture
much harder very smart people can finish
them in no time at all but to be honest
they're not exciting so they don't even
make a picture in the end feels much
more worth it if you do like him okay
all right
he stays dome in fleeting thoughts on a
moonlit night so this ghost iben guy he
uh imparted his spirits into his work
such that they took in life oh hi
statues blocking away hmm whoa good
thing I'm so strong Hey pull the cord
would that do but what did it do what
did it do hey there's writing here uh
what is the title of the large floor
painting of guerre tannaz exhibition
could it be a password the big fish
painting right I did see it something of
the deep denizens of the deep
was that it oh goodness realm of the
deep abyss of the deep
I don't know none of you seem to fit
picture of the deep I'm gonna go with
abyss
cuz that sounds pretty nice miss of the
deep that was it abyss of the deep did
you read the title let's remember it are
you sure
are you aren't wait are you are you
really sure about that Gary oh I could
solve it I know I can
I could've solved that puzzle dang it I
didn't mean to leave fine you know what
abyss of the deep okay but
oh did it work was that right separation
what an off-putting painting you're
off-putting it's too dark to see Eve are
you there what why would I say I'm not
there uh Eve are you there Oh No
what do I do no you're there you should
have said something you worried me but
this is a problem yeah that's right
forgot I had a lighter okay okay oh okay
like that part from Ione when that
monster came in he hid from it and it
scribbled all over the walls that was
disturbing I don't think it was good for
my mental health
well then Gary maybe you toughen up a
bit I I do know my finger over her
beautiful what with her see look Gary
close the book oh oh okay why not Gary I
guess that proves that I am just a
little kid
goodness gracious goodness whoa there's
a strict ban on fire-starting implements
in the gallery the crest of what oh
you're talking about Gary's lighter okay
oh well I there seems to be some
footy-prints or going over here let me
save
I'm beginning to think that the Guerre
table guy is all watch what aisles
getting flashbacks from the wishes house
you ah
kaboosh Wow are you okay Oh am i ah wait
ere you could you be one of the visitors
to the gallery ah as I thought I'm Gary
and this girl's Eve you're in the art
gallery but then somehow found ourselves
lost in this place so now we're both
trying to find a way out presumably
you're doing the same I I was looking to
see if there was anyone else to I wanted
to get out so I I knew it well would you
like to come with us huh it's dangerous
to go alone take this there are a lot of
strange creatures around so will you
come with us I think it would be best if
we don't stay together wooden I don't
trust this lady decided what's your name
Mary oh really Gary and Mary Gary and
Mary I don't like the sound of this
nice to meet you Eve nice to meet you
too fine I'll be polite Thanks
all right now we can proceed more
company you proceed with our spirits
high Z are you are you are you sure
that's what we want to do here I'm gonna
yeah you know what I'm gonna hey I'm I'm
okay with it if you if you're okay with
it I'm okay with it that lady in the
painting is a yellow dress blue blue all
right so say seeing as Eve and I both
have roses Mary do you have a rose as
well yeah I do a yellow rose that's true
you to keep those Dave don't you dare
lose it and don't give it to anyone hand
wow EOBs roses read mine is yellow
I like yellow and I also like pink and
blue learn to listen would you oh she's
just your blind I've heard those blonde
jokes since like the early Audis
did you know they call the 2000s like
the zero zero the Audis they really do
look it up it's true don't look at me
like that it's true I wouldn't lie to
you guys it's true I believe what you
want to believe flowers of jealousy like
yellow flowers are guilty oh boy
marshmallow peeps but one is green why
is one green it's an adorable bunny
how's it gonna turn awful why must it be
so unsettling I think it's cute what
about this is cute I'm not so sure
well alright then okay well I mean it
wasn't too creepy it advocates in the
beginning but what more worrying yet I'm
just at the back what does that mean
okay all right all right okay all right
got a violet key all right you know what
I'm out of here don't even nothing about
nobody what the hell what huh
that sounds getting closer whoa
so they came out of the ground I'll get
away from the painting
watch out oh my no Gary don't leave me
with Mary Oh
oh no I'm not hurt good with these
things in the way I can't get over there
maybe I can cut it down way what's this
these vines are made of stone but what
to do hey Eve you got a key in that room
right
maybe that key opens that door there oh
really oh really
hey we should look no Gary I don't trust
Mary we'll be fine right I'd rather not
split up why not
we'll be back really quick I can't think
of anything else huh I suppose you're
right there isn't much else that seems
viewable but if you don't find anything
make sure you come right back okay then
we'll fairy think about what we can do
yeah got it okay let's go okay let's No
Gary Gary Gary Oh Don
oh no I don't wanna be with Mary Mary
a palette knife I doubt it you're stupid
I just got a bad feeling about this
guy's I just got a really bad feeling
about this
what did I get wha huh Oh babban
oh come on that statue really the statue
moved huh move it Eve
won't even budge what do we do we can't
get out fine we'll go this way then
marry I marry we're leaving oh good oh
hey how about that there seems to be a
ball falling oh I was gonna catch it I
was gonna catch it God dingus fine you
know what whatever I want you to have
fun EEB come to a fun world without any
adults we'll be together
you me and our friends doesn't sound
good
this is kind of left him behind yeah
that was a bad thing Oh
oh wait a minute they're taking their
time I wonder if something happened hey
Mary can you hear me no they cannot no
good ah I knew I shouldn't have let them
go alone
what to do
I suppose I'll investigate that room
again as much as I hate to go back in
there alright then
this guy's got ten ten oh my I wasn't
even looking at that house look at the
roses I didn't see that whoa
oh is not all he saw something different
he saw different oh-oh-oh-oh
a disturbing dolly a bunch of disturbing
dollies you got that right friend
nothing of note here hmm oh it moved why
didn't I notice that earlier I don't
know maybe distracted by all the
diabolical dolls hanging around my head
got too hard on himself
maybe you should be nicer hi ah there's
no exit there is no reason toward hangs
I'm not just gonna blindly pull cords
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go back cuz
this is obviously a portal doodad save
there no I see so there's five cords
there I'm obviously pulling the cords so
I pull the forth one will the painting
fall and allow me to cross over is that
what this deal is all about hold it yank
a Rooney oh no oh that was anticlimactic
hahahaha alright then I guess that's
good give me can I walk on your face
stare intently hello friend
are you doing is it okay to cross yes
it's okay gimme another that something's
moving inside evil it's not open that
box oh how about we do um I want to open
it oh crap I messed up there whoops my
bad I keep messing things up and then I
don't get a chance to go back and fix it
hey then go back and fix it do it push
this into the pit of death yeah yeah how
do you like that
Gary you like that Giri
Hey look at that it would wait
Bing bong do I want to go in here the
answer is hell yeah maybe maybe maybe oh
hello little dolly hello there Gary I
don't like being alone take me with you
alright then wait I wanna I wanna I was
gonna take you with me oh hi
hey why are you taking me uh I wanna oh
hi are you ignoring me do you hate me uh
Gary you might want to listen to the
dolly hey play with me I know lots of
fun things we can do okay like what like
what I've got lots of friends too I'll
introduce you no thank you
be here forever and ever and ever and
ever
how long are you going to follow me
enough of this I'm busy here and I'm not
gonna be your buddy kick it into the
wall move it out of the way move it very
gently out of the way it would be best
not to get involved here it's locked
take me oh thank you
maybe I should take it no I can't take
it
Gary ain't gonna take it it's locked
doorknob is strangely cold why is that
strange disturbing dolly I'll always be
with you my home is just nearby
hey so this looks nice
okay collect the seven balls of paint
then the room will be colored in your
bridge will be made balls of paint I
wonder where those are I let one of
those balls of paint fall down I didn't
mean to but it happened okay well then
well then Dave this is the painting from
the beginning of the game I don't know
if he was called worried voice comes
from the painting what year was I born
well I was born 1989 what I mean I
you you were born oh why you gotta be
like that bruh fishing hook locked well
this seems like to be a whole lot of
nothing
oh my what is this room don't want to
stay here oh oh my the ball of paint an
advantage oh my oh I died oh come on he
didn't even give me a chance
well thank you for that that was lovely
you you're awesome you're just the best
there ever was
get the ball payment oh I'm gonna get a
get a get in oh come on it's hard it's
hard to be precise with these controls
I'm gonna blame it on the controls again
cuz I blame it always on the controls
okay what is this room gonna go yeah oh
yeah this beard and go go go yeah buddy
then I got the Vaz here push rose goody
goody gumdrops we're good we're so good
now what else do I need to do I guess I
go back to the other side Boeing and
then what what do we do I guess we just
carry on until we find a EEB can I ask
you something no Mary shut up Gary your
dad nope
so your dad is somebody else I see your
mom nice not when she's mad he gets mad
at you even want to see your parents
soon right I want to get out soon too
hey Eva if only two of us could get out
of here then what
I don't like making choices I don't like
it
I wouldn't I I'd surrender myself cuz
I'm noble like that really EEB but then
you'd never meet your mom again it would
be really lonely you know don't say
things like that we'll leave together
promise you asked a question lady why
I'm the leader
I'm the tiny little girl that's the
leader of this group apparently okay
alright whatever Fisher man hey wait no
it was a fishhook in the other painting
oh I don't need to heal I'm frying
tattletale
hey it's the lips again what does that
mean heavenly thread hey it's a picture
from limbo I love that game skin and
skin in some word that she doesn't know
can we put in a name that one was
worried
no that one was marvelous night oh the
worry was the eyeball that's why I
remembered worried I was like that was
the one that Gary saw over on his side
okay okay okay I'll ride out ride out
ride girl went with her parents to the
gallery but all's done the girl realized
that she was lost
sheets are through the dim gallery but
found neither her parents nor the exit
I'm rapping freestyle scared Noblet blow
me hungry and thirsty she fell and hurt
herself putting her body
Pat the limit laughs Paige was an
illustration of a collapse girl that
doesn't sound good
sorry for the horrible rap I would
understand if you guys just decided to
unsubscribe right now okay lady in red
1660 210 it was sad that he based this
on a lover he had at the time but he
denied this claim Guertin have based it
around the bill woman who attempt to
court him from his inheritance I don't
know some of the words what does it mean
a lone keyhole um the moon fish six two
three five despite being grayscale who's
curious piece makes clever use of
shading and angles giving birth good
code uh hang on wait a minute I write
down some of these numbers um
juggling six two six two two three work
based on a juggler he saw at the circus
with his grandchild it was an extremely
rare for groom people okay does that
mean hang on let me just get the other
ones real quick
I'll page
one zero zero lady in red and then hey
those that painting that I got the code
from the up sound died down guy but he
had six two nine five on his shirt I
guess that was the number of his
painting like this is all about Guerre
Thibodeau but I don't know how it
relates I don't know that's true what's
going on here still not sure but I'm
thinking making some progress anyway
that's all the time I got for this
episode I'm gonna finish this up soonish
well I don't know I'm a later left go
I've been playing this in one big
sitting so but I've been progressing so
you can't yell at me right right right
you probably you're probably still
yelling at me so anyway thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
you
God decreed
those old